let's give people the latest on the
situation in ukraine where russian
troops are closing in on the capital of
kiev and the mayor says that the defense
of the city is underway it has begun the
fighting is happening you can see
explosions high above keeve as russian
attacks escalated this morning
at this hour more than 130 ukrainians
among them civilians have been killed
and that number could be a low estimate
president biden vows that a new round of
sanctions will impose severe cost on
russia's economy these new sanctions
target russian banks oligarchs and their
families also high-tech exports however
they stopped short of hitting russia's
energy industry or cutting russia out of
the swift payment system that allows
banks and money transfers all around the
globe for more on all of it let's go to
republican senator ben sasse of nebraska
he's joining us from capitol hill he is
a member of the senate select committee
on intelligence senator good morning
thank you for being here
before this latest round of sanctions uh
you called the president's approach to
putin too little too late have you
changed that view hearing what came out
yesterday
i am glad that the administration
increased the sanctions yesterday
there's still a lot more to do your
graphic there showed the difference
between some of the sanctions that have
been levied and some that haven't uh
let's talk about why the ones that
haven't been levied should be added to
the list but before sanctions let's just
back up and say at an intelligence and a
defense level we've done some things but
we've not done enough at an intelligence
level one of the things that the u.s
intelligence community did that we'll
look back on as really important is we
intentionally got out to the world how
putin who's a constant liar was planning
to lie to create a pretext for his
invasion nobody believes now that
ukraine was a threat to him because the
u.s intelligence community did a good
job of showing what he was constructing
as a lie to justify this completely
unjustifiable
invasion of its peaceful neighborhood
you're right senator you're absolutely
right the intel community did do an
amazingly precise job here they they got
it right and we should note that
on the subject of getting it right
though in hindsight was there anything
that the u.s government could have done
might have done to prevent this which
now feels like an inevitable takeover of
ukraine absolutely uh going back to 2014
we should have been arming the
ukrainians putin
poisoned political opponents in 2004. he
invades georgia in 2008 he invades
ukraine and takes crimea in 2014 he
shoots down a civilian airliner again
and again without consequences 2016 he
medals in the u.s election he poisons
navalny again in 2020 he amasses 150 000
troops on the border and the us and and
europe are just sort of slumbering giant
saying well hopefully he doesn't mean
bad here's who putin is he means bad
he's evil he has big weapons he has big
will you may think he's a genius you may
think he's a madman but he's got will
and he's got weapons we can't be
indifferent to this we should have been
arming the ukrainians a lot more to date
and we need to do more starting now
senator we've been talking about the
global oil prices soaring
and the administration says that
targeting the
energy industry would only hurt
americans at the pump should americans
be willing to pay more
to end this crisis
well first the american people have to
understand that the last 77 years going
back to 1945 have known unbelievable
peace and one of the benefits for that
has been unbelievable prosperity but the
world is a broken and dangerous place
there are lots of sinners all of us are
in our hearts but not everybody has
putin's weapons and we need to recognize
that appeasement has never worked
against a man like putin he'll have to
be stopped at some point let's be clear
nobody's talking about putting troops on
the ground in ukraine but we need to be
absolutely certain that putin
understands that we and all of our nato
allies stand together and that we will
arm the ukrainians and that we're going
to put pressure on people like germany
who've been unwilling to cut off the
nordstrom 2 pipeline which is one of the
main sources of cash for putin so the
administration has a very important
internal debate which is legitimate
about whether or not certain energy
sanctions could drive up prices in ways
that could accidentally benefit putin
because to quote john mccain
russia is mostly just a gas station
masquerading as a nation right now
our battle is not with the 200 million
russian people 200 plus
but it is with vladimir putin the madman
and so there are important internal
debates about specific tactics around
energy sanctions but the american people
need to be brought along to understand
that peace and prosperity comes because
the u.s has secured a global order that
made it the case that people like putin
couldn't just dance across borders like
we see happening now he will have to be
stopped senator sasse i think you'll
appreciate this story i was in la last
week and i went to a food truck because
i liked fine dining and i was placing my
order and i noticed that the woman had
an accent i asked her where she was from
and she said ukraine i said oh my gosh
you're from ukraine what are you
thinking about what is happening in your
country she said we think you all are
exaggerating we're fine i've talked to
my relatives my family we're shopping
the kids are playing in the street we're
grocery shopping i called her last night
senator and she said now everything the
american government and the american
media said was true
and now we are shocked and we are
shattered and we just want people to
help us
so i want to know outside of sanctions
and arming the ukrainian people
what can we what should we do i just
heard you say we need to do more but
what does that look like because now the
people of ukraine in the last 48 hours
the last three days really are totally
shattered by this it's yeah even though
it's predicted they're very surprised
thanks for your story gail i've heard
similar stories from ukrainians in
nebraska over the last 48 hours so we
talked about defense uh president biden
needs to send an emergency supplemental
defense request to the congress now and
we need to be arming the ukrainians we
need to be sharing actionable and
actionable intelligence with ukrainian
resistors and with their military so
they can kill the invading russians we
need to have more sanctions but we also
need to have a kind of lifestyles of the
rich and famous made for tv uh russian
jackasses in london show where people
understand why the ukrainian
billionaires who've been enabling putin
need to be perp-walked out of western
and free countries and sent back to live
in the hellhole tyranny that putin wants
to create moscow these guys are getting
rich off enabling putin but they don't
really want to live as his next door
neighbor because they know the guy's
unstable they know the world is
dishonorable if putin has more power and
so we need people in london we need the
british government to step up with more
targeted sanctions against russian
billionaires in their city we we need to
be doing a lot more that also prepares
for the refugee crisis that's coming to
poland and beyond and i'll commend the
president yesterday at sending more u.s
troops uh to poland and recognizing that
the immigrant crisis that's going to
flood west into poland and germany is
going to have a humanitarian element
where you're going to need a lot of u.s
manpower to help with some of that
senator ben sasse never uh one who holds
back and you didn't this morning we
appreciate it uh we'll have you back
soon as the
crisis continues in ukraine we
appreciate it thank you thanks for the
invite tony